hallo Leute ich habe eine eigene
Kerze designed und den Duft ausgesucht
sie ist handmade in Deutschland sie ist
aus 100% sojawachs und ich würde sagen
sie riecht in der Kopfnote ungefähr nach
Himbeer orange Eukalyptus Frischluft
Akkord die Herznote ist rote
johannesbeere wilder Salbei und
zuckerfeilchen jetzt so ganz spontan und
die Basisnote ist patchuli in Sandelholz
Kokosnussschale und definitiv
Vanillezucker sie riecht einfach wie ein
toller winterlicher Abend Ich lieb es
also die ist wirklich mein kleines Baby
ich habe das alles hier selber Design
das habe ich zum allerersten Mal gemacht
und ich bin wirklich stolz wie sie
rausgekommen ist also falls ihr noch vor
Weihnachten sie haben wollt dann solltet
ihr wirklich sehr schnell bestellen es
gibt noch ein paar die produziert wurden
ansonsten werden noch welche
nachproduziert und ja viel Spaß der Link
ist unten in der Videobeschreibung hey
Leute ich fahre gerade in Berlin nicht
im Dorf das ist richtiges Autofahren
hier aber es ist Samstag deswegen ist es
nicht so strengt jetzt kommt eine krasse
Rechtskurve alle
festhalten wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg
zur Hochzeitslocation Nummer 1 also ich
habe mal eine rausgesucht die ich noch
von früher kannte und wollte sie einfach
mal mit tetimo besuchen um zu schauen ob
wir uns dort vorstellen können zu
heiraten und ja seit ich Skifahren kann
kann ich auch in Berlin Autofahren ganz
easy habe einfach gelernt
Angst hält ich auf wer Angst hat leidet
zweimal den Spruch hab ich von Mar das
muss da muss ich jetzt die Credits
abgeben ja ansonsten neuer Mensch jetzt
Skifahren und damit willkommen zu
vlogmas Tag 17 Bo nur noch 7 Tage nur
noch eine Woche dann haben es geschafft
ja schauen wir uns mal an hoffentlich
könen wir dort Filmen ich weiß nicht ob
wir dort filmen können aber seht ihr
dann
dann Auto gehört habt wir fahren gerade
zur Hochzeitslocation und dort habe ich
auch extra gefragt hey ist das in
Ordnung dass wir für vlogmas Film habe i
das kurz erklärt und sie hat gesagt na
klar gar kein Problem aber aus
irgendeinem Grund war das Timo trotzdem
unangenehm das heißt wir haben halt
nicht viele Aufnahmen wo ich spreche und
deswegen gibt's jetzt von mir noch mal
Kommentare zu allem was so passiert
[Musik]
ist
so wir sind da ungefähr eine Stunde
fährt man hierher ich weiß jetzt aber
nicht wo wir die Person begrüßen müssen
wir werden rausfinden wir werden es
rausfinden angekommen im Schloss wurden
wir erstmal von der Hausherrin empfangen
und sie hat uns dann reingeführt und
dort haben uns erstmal drei Seele
begrüßt ein gelber ein blauer und ein
roter oh mein Gott wie
schön kann ich mir auch richtig gut
vorstellen als so den abendra den
polterabendraum weißt du mit so einem
brennenden Kamin mir hat der rote Raum
am besten gefallen weil der einfach so
eine christmasy gemütliche
Weihnachtsstimmung ausgestrahlt hat
liegt wahrscheinlich auch daran dass
dort ein Kamin gebrannt hat jeder Raum
hat auch ein originalkamin aus 1700
schieß mich tot also wirklich überall
ist da einfach so historisch die Bilder
die Möbel alles ist richtig alt und das
sieht man auch aber es ist total süß
zusammengewürfelt also es hat so ein
richtig eigenen Charakter und Scham so
dass fast das Auge und das Hirn
überfordert ist wenn man das alles sieht
und das alles zum ersten Mal so aufnimmt
kleiner fun fact ich war schon mal in
diesem Schloss vor 8 Jahren mit Studio
71 meinem YouTube Netzwerk die Youtuber
auch also ich hatte damals in dem Haus
hier geschlafen was wunderschön war und
viele Youtuber haben dann ja auch im
Stall ja auch was besonderes ist also es
macht ja auch Spaß genau und dann haben
wir Fuß läuf ich inzwischen
mindestens 40 Übernachtungsplätze noch
im Dorf ganzern ja super das also ich
glaube ja schlafen geht hier auf jeden
Fall ne über den Eingangsbereich wo man
auch wirklich sieht dass hier ein großer
Bezug zu Pferden ist kommt man nach oben
ins erste Stockwerk und dort erwarten
ein die Schlafzimmer also da sind super
viele Räume und das ist super groß aber
was natürlich ganz besonders ins Auge
fällt sind diese Master bedrooms wo dann
z.B auch das Brautpaar schlafen kann und
ja es ist sehr beeindruckend und alles
natürlich auch wieder sehr sehr alt
teilweise sogar ganze originale das das
haben wir freigelegt das ist die
originalbemalung von
1740 WoW und die zweiten die zweiten
dass die Fassung hier wenn man das mit
muskapell ganz vorsichtig feilgen würde
würde man auch Muster kriegen oben ja
dass man hier wirklich so schlafen kann
das sieht aus wie eine
Museum
sch vor alle wohn auch in dem Schloss so
oh das ist auch toll oh dieser Schrank
also ist auch wirklich alt ist echt
alt der Schrank ist echt alt also wir
haben jetzt die Rundführung durchs
Schloss hier gemacht und es fühlt sich
einfach an als ob man in einem Museum
drin wäre jeder Raum ist einfach
so schön aber nicht so ästhetisch schön
wie wie so ein Designer das Design hätte
sondern einfach schön weil man darin
einfach so diese Geschichte dahinter
erkennt ja jetzt geht und jetzt geht's
nach draußen jetzt geht's nach draußen
ach so süß
weißen hier so Äpfel es riecht hier auch
so richtig es riecht hier wie in so
alten Haus
ne ganz kalt weil hier natürlich jetzt
gerade keiner ist und das Pferd ist toll
mit diesem Pferd habe ich vor 8 Jahren
mal Fotos
gemacht ach so die roten
Augen ja es ist ja auch so ein Reiter
reitgut ich weiß nicht wie man es genau
nennt das erkennt man auch an z.B
überall so Pferde und Sattel z.B einfach
hier Sattel sind einfach überall so
random und dann hat uns der hausher
begrüßt und wir sind nach draußen
gegangen und hier könnt ihr noch mal
sehen wie schön das Schloss eigentlich
ist es ist wie aus einem Märchen einfach
so
rausgeholt
rüber zu den Apartments denn wir
brauchen bei einer Hochzeit natürlich
auch Gäste und diese Gäste sollten
idealerweise auch ein Schlafplatz haben
wir planen eine wochenendhochzeit das
heißt am Freitag gibt's den Polterabend
am Samstag wird die Hochzeit gefeiert
und am Sonntag noch ein schönes
abschiedsbrunch und dann können auch mal
alle wieder gehen ja und dafür braucht
man natürlich Schlafplätze und dieses
Schloss hat wirklich die Besonderheit
dass es sehr viele Schlafmöglichkeiten
hat wie z.B auch im Pferdestall und im
ehemaligen man schläft nicht im
Pferdestall man schläft im ehemaligen
Pferdestall und dort haben wir auch dann
draußen zwei Pferde gesehen die zu dem
Hof
gehören ja ich weiß nicht ob die so toll
ich glaube die wollen
reingehen ach so oder sind die die
Kinder die hier sind das ist es glaube
ich ja wundert mich dass sie so
aufgeregt
sind alles klar wir erwarten dass sie
irgendwas von den Kriegen
und da oben sind auch ist sind auch
[Musik]
nochohn das ist so gemütlich ich weiß
nicht mal wie man diesen Stil
nennt Stuhl da aussieht wie aus dem
Filmset es wundert mich dass es gar
nicht so verstaubt hier alles ist ne
also das ganze Anwesen ist hier so groß
da könnten wirklich alle Leute
unterkriegen und schaut euch mal an es
ist so e so sieht so guck dir mal diesen
Tisch alleine an das ist man fühlt sich
wie so einem antikwarenladen ne so ein
bisschen es ist alles sind so
Einzelstücke sieht so cool auch schon
wieder hier aus und diese Küchen sind
die ausgestattet einfach ausgestattete
Küchen
falls jemand während unser Hochzeit
kochen möchte können Sie es gerne machen
ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben so
eine majesthätische Lampe gesehen und
die hängt hier einfach so oh eine kleine
Musikanlage können wir unsere CDs
mitbringen warte ich fange an mich zu
erinnern hier habe ich geschlafen und
dann lag ich hier frisch
geduscht mit meinem Bademantel die
Fenster waren auf die Vögel haben
gezwitschert und ich lag hier drin und
war richtig
so Ruhe und dann bin ich hier
raus ich bin so verwirrt und nachdem wir
gefühlt 500 Schlafplätze gesehen haben
ging es dann rüber zur alten Schmiede
hier könnt ihr noch mal sehen dass es
einen sehr großen Bezug zu Pferden gibt
und gab es wurde auch gesagt dass man
eine Schmiede immer daran erkennt dass
sie ganz abgesetzt von den restlichen
Häusern ist also dass es da so eine
Brandgefahr gibt dass man halt ja den
Abstand zum Rest schön groß halten
möchte dort findet dann auch das
Frühstück statt und da hatte ich sofort
Flashbacks weil ich kann mich sehr gut
daran erinnern wie die Anfang 20jährige
Vanessa dort saß vielleicht mit einem
ganz leichten Kater vom Vorabend sich
dort ein Brötchen geschmiert hat ich
erinnere mich wir haben hier
gefrühstückt genau richtig ja ja hier
haben wir gefrühstückt ja ach so und
hier findet dann also hier ist ja auch
dann super für Frühstück oder ich
erinnere mich ja das ist cool hier zu
frühstücken dann ne so Frühstücksbrunch
zu machen wenn das Wetter gut draußen
gut ist dann sitzt man noch draußen man
merkt auf jeden Fall dass die
Hausherrinnen sehr viel Erfahrung haben
mit Hochzeiten wir haben uns draußen so
ein bisschen unterhalten ob wir z.B auch
ein weddingpler in brauchen oder nicht
und wo man die Hochzeit richtig
ja also wo die Trauung stattfinden kann
und da hat er uns z.B auch diese
Eichenallee empfohlen im Sommer ist es
natürlich toll wenn man im Schatten
heiraten kann denn in so einer prallen
Sonne möchte ich eigentlich auch nicht
ja sagen wenn dann die Sonne dir so ins
Gesicht knallt ja ich will Hochzeiten
gehabt drinen Verstand und in
interessant es waren zwei Hochzeiten die
wo die Frau unbedingt hoch zu Ross
heiraten wollte ach cool nein und das W
dann Doppel cool das war diese
Taiwanese Taiwanesin und der californiia
ja die wollte auch hoch zu Ross heiraten
Timo kann dann im besten Fall auch mit
einem pferrd zum Altar finde ich toll
wenn Prinz Charming mich dort
begüßt so und das ist dann in der
eichenalle so mittend drin so vielleicht
70 80 m oder 100 m dazwischen ja da
kommt dann der Pavillon hin und Stühle
und was immer soll
ah das ist ja auch cool ne Timo das
sieht natürlich jetzt durch den durch
den Regen ja na ja und nichts grün schön
gerade wenn man daran denkt wenn es im
Sommer also wenn es ein sehr warmer Tag
ist dann ist natürlich schön wenn man
dann genau es ist wirklich schön ist
dann schattig und es ist ein bisschen
windig ja ja nebenan stehen die Pferde
auch rum das ist ein sehr schönes
[Musik]
sandieren das ist was ganz was
besonderes das ist ein Katzenhaus aber
nicht me
Katzenhaus schon Katzenhaus mit zuesehen
nein nicht ernst nicht nur
fußbrunheizung das da
ist das kommt in der
Mikrowelle
cool die sind sehr tierlie
wahrscheinlich meine Frau ist in Katz ah
ja meine Freundin auch und das war's
dann auch eigentlich schon mit der Tour
hier seht ihr noch einmal den Garten und
wir haben es natürlich auch schon Pläne
gemacht dass wir draußen ein Zelt
hinstellen mit Lichterketten wir haben
ganz viele tolle Pinterest Bilder
gesehen was dort natürlich sehr gut
möglich ist im roten Raum saßen wir dann
noch mal bei Christ Stollen und Tee und
haben über Feinheiten gesprochen also
über Preise was wie möglich ist wie
lange etwas dauert und ja das war's dann
erstmal wir wollen uns natürlich auch
noch andere Locations anschauen einfach
nur um einen Vergleich zu haben wir
finden diese Location schon mega toll
wir wissen aber auch dass da wohl viel
Arbeit noch hintersteckt wenn man sowas
wie ein Zelt haben möchte oder dann halt
irgendwelche extra Wünsche Tische raus
Stühle rein also es gibt einfach so viel
zu tun deswegen bin ich noch nicht ganz
so sicher ob wir mit einer weddingplerin
arbeiten oder nicht wir haben schon
Anfragen bekommen als ich habe von einer
Zuschauerin richtig Liebe Nachicht
gekriegt und war auch schon bisschen im
Kontakt mit ihr und ich tendiere schon
dazu einfach nur weil ich ja auch an dem
Hochzeitstag oder wir uns entspannen
wollen ich rede immer von ich aber ich
meine natürlich bei allem wir
timo ist da auch super mit drin und
diese ganze Tour hat uns schon so eine
so ein Kribbeln im Bauch gemacht weil
man natürlich jetzt diese Hochzeit das
ist wie so ein Brautkleid anziehen so es
wird schon bisschen realer und
greifbarer und ich bin gespannt was
jetzt so die nächsten Wochen Monate
angeht was wir noch uns so anschauen
werden wir werden euch das natürlich
alles nicht zeigen können weil ich ja
auch eine Youtube Pause mache am Anfang
des Jahres und ja das ist jetzt
natürlich für vlogmas konnte ich euch
dieses schmanele geben ja und dann sehen
wir uns morgen wieder ne
tschüssi
I just make
my